the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so today I'm mostly going to talk about
two formulas that we are going to make a
lot of use of one is a time derivative
of linear momentum which will be used a
lot has got to be equal to for a
particle will these new particles today
and then rigid bodies soon so for a
particle this is just the mass times the
acceleration of the particle the rigid
body it's the mass total mass times
acceleration of the center of gravity
and the other formula that we've learned
that we've come up to is the sum of the
external torques with respect to a point
a on us on on a particle is the time
derivative of the angular momentum of
the particle at B with respect to a DT
and then it's got this nuisance term
this velocity of a with respect to O
cross the linear momentum at the point B
with respect to O so we talked about
this last time so this is a particle
that's located out here at B there's
some intermediate point a and we're
computing the angular momentum of this
particle M with respect to a and a can
be moving and if it is when you go to
compute torques you have to use this
kind of messy formula we often stri to
simplify the problems that we do so that
we can either make a fixed axis of
rotation make it rotate about this point
which case this goes to zero or there's
another time when you can make the
velocity of this point parallel to the
velocity at that point and the most
common one is one of all is when you
make you use this
formerly about the center of mass then
the motion velocity to the center of
mass is the same direction as the
momentum and therefore this term goes to
zero so we have these two cases where
this formula simplifies so the way we're
you most often use it is a summation of
the torques with respect to a is just
the derivative of the angular momentum
DT and that's it this is when the a is
zero or VA is parallel to P and such as
a is at the center of mass okay so these
are the two formulas that we want to use
unless you do a real simple case first
and this is just my string my mass on a
string spinning around constant speed
okay and I'm going to pretend I'm on a
frictionless table so I don't have to
deal with gravity this thing is
horizontal just spinning around and I'll
call this point a this is my point O
this is X Z nope
why looking down on it okay so it's
going to have a velocity in this theta
hat direction and vector r hat will just
use polar coordinates of the velocity of
a with respect to O we know and we'll
give this just a length magnitude R 1 so
this is going to be a theta dot equals a
constant r dot equals 0 so it's just
fixed length fixed length is R 1 so
what's we know the simple formula for
the velocity of that is R 1 theta dot in
the theta hat direction
it has accused me okay in the momentum
then this is the mass times that and the
time derivative of the linear momentum
respect to this fixed reference frame is
the time derivative of this this is
constant this is constant this is
constant the only thing you have to take
is the derivative of theta hat so this
is M R 1
theta dot theta hat time derivative but
we've worked that one out two or three
times it's theta dot minus theta dot R
hat okay put that in you get minus mr1
theta dot squared R hat and this must be
the sum of the external forces and if we
looking down on this draw Freebody
diagram of our mass looking down on it
here's our hat I theta direction like
this Z coming out of the board so this
is X Y and O there is a inward force on
it that we call the tension in the
string and some of the current internal
force is this minus T R hat so T is mr1
theta dot squared which is what we
talked about just a second ago so this
is just a demonstration of what we were
talking about with the survey questions
that when you spin something you're
changing its linear momentum not in
magnitude it stays constant but it's
constantly changing in direction and the
direction change you have to take this
derivative gives you you the sent
direction changes that causes the
centripetal acceleration to caused that
acceleration you have to put a force on
it and the forces that inward tension in
the string okay so there that's the
really that's the first really simple
one now let's take a
now let's do the same problem that let
it be a little bit more general I've got
a table top this problems in described
in the book as an example you got a hole
in the table because your mass out here
so this is looking down on the table and
down through the hole coming out the
bottom of the hole you have the string
and you pull on it so r dot looking down
on it this thing again has some theta R
hat directions like this theta hat
directions like that this thing spinning
going around around my table top but as
a whole in a table top and I can pull
the string and shorten the string so our
dots are constant theta dot will not be
a constant okay it will be it will
change this is my vector R
so the velocity will call this a this is
my origin oh the velocity in this case
of the particle with respect the fixed
inertial frame is r dot R hat plus R
theta dot theta hat and now it has two
possible velocities and I'm going to be
pulling it in and it's going to be going
round and round so the linear momentum
is just M VA with respect to O
okay
so with this problem if I take the time
derivative of linear momentum he
recognize this this is just in this is
just velocity in polar coordinates we've
done this derivative before to get the
acceleration so the acceleration time
derivative of a with respect to O is the
acceleration of a with respect to O but
we and that's a messy formula but we've
and we've derived it before so that
looks like and it's got four terms R
double dot minus R theta dot squared and
the R hat plus R theta double dot plus 2
r dot theta dot in the data hat
direction and it multiplied by the mass
that should be that's the total that's
the mass times the acceleration and this
needs this would be equal to the sum of
all the external forces acting on that
particle that's Newton's second law
but in our problem here I've said this
is constant which I can throw out this
term is going to be zero so this term
goes away but this term certainly not
zero this term is not necessarily 0 this
term is certainly not zero so what can
we do with that so now's the time you do
so draw some Freebody diagrams and let's
look at the side view the side view here
is your particle mg down some normal
force up and attention pulling in
alright so the tables supporting it
gravity down and just the string force
pulling it in the top view you're
looking down on it I'm not allowing I'm
assuming it's frictionless table so
there's no friction so the only force
seen from the top is detention there are
no forces in that in the plane in the
direction theta hat okay so the sum of
the external forces in the theta hat
direction are in this direction this is
so the total force is on this thing from
your free body diagram in the theta hat
direction are zero and that allows us to
take this term and set it equal zero
this is the X so theta hat the piece is
equal to zero is equal to M R theta
double dot plus 2 r dot theta dot that
is you can solve this for that's equal
to zero so R theta double dot equal
minus 2 r dot theta dot so in order for
this thing to satisfy Newton's law
happens to be that as you pull it in the
product of r dot and theta dot gives you
the angular acceleration okay and the
other term we just went through that
that's what we did a couple minutes ago
in the the force in the R hat direction
some of the forces is a derivative of
the linear momentum is minus M R theta
dot squared R hat and we know from the
free body diagram that that better be
equal to minus T R hat direction so just
like before tells you the T equals M R
theta dot squared so the mass times
intend trip Atal acceleration in order
to make that sin trip Atal motion happen
you have to pull on it with the force M
R theta dot squared
so what can you say about the angular
momentum of this particle with respect
to Oh
so let's write it up so H of the
particle with respect to O is our a o
cross P this is our R hat cross and now
P
so R cross R you get nothing from that
term R cross R hat cross theta hat gives
you a k a positive K so you get R
our R squared theta dot in the K
direction
and I'm missing something there we go
mr squared theta dot right because M R
theta dot is the linear momentum times
another R gives you the angular momentum
M R squared theta dot and because our
hat cross theta hat is K this angular
momentum is directed upward about the
center of rotation so that's our
expression for our angular momentum
but if you take the time derivative of
it
what should it tell us let's go back to
that our for our formulas we started
with when the center of rotation is not
moving when they're pointed which with
respect to which you're taking the
angular momentum doesn't move then
that's one of the cases where you can
get rid of those extra terms so in this
case we're computing the angular
momentum with respect to O which doesn't
move the velocity of O here is zero so
this allows us just to say that the sum
of the torques with respect about o is
just equal to the time rate of change of
H with respect to O and to do that the
this term can change and this term can
change but how about the derivative of K
it stays it's just constant right so
we're going to get two terms out of this
we're going to get em to our r dot
theta dot k plus R squared theta double
dot okay what are the torques in the
what are the external torques in this
problem you have to pretend that I'm on
a frictionless table top here when I'm
going around like this what are the what
are the torques about the center point
so what are the first one of the forces
acting on the mass just attention and
the tension cross the moment arm the
tensions in the R hat direction the
string is in the r direction our hat
cross r hat is zero so there's no
torques so for this problem this is
equal to zero okay and that then allows
us to write
the M cancels out obviously and I can
get rid of one of these ours goes away
and I'm left with an r dot theta dot and
I move this to the other side equal to
minus R theta double dot and that's what
we came up with a minute ago when we
were doing the the when we did the just
the time derivative of the linear
momentum we learned this we haven't
learned much more it's just telling us
that well this thing's going to
accelerate as you pull it in and it'll
accelerate at at any instant time
whatever r dot is Theta dot is this will
be the angular acceleration
okay so what's what will happen then
let's let let's do two two points in
time
and we'll let our two equals our 1/2 so
I'm just going to pull this thing in so
let's do the experiment yeah I'm going
to pull it in about half its length you
can speed up slow down stay the same
speed alright get it going in okay I'll
try not to a I'll move over here so I
hate hands death okay let's try it again
alright but there's no torques on it
there's no torque being applied the
angular momentum is constant and yet the
thing speeds up so I want to ask you get
actually question check do you think the
kinetic energy is staying the same or
changing so how many think the kinetic
energy as I go from out there to in here
the kinetic energy stays the same
okay how many think it's different all
right how many are not so sure let's
find out so we've determined that if
this is zero then that means that H with
respect to H a with respect to O is a
constant so H this is a t1 is our r1
better be faster if I look at my notes
so the angular momentum at r1 is M r1
squared theta 1 dot in the K direction
and that it better be equal to H at r2
and that will be M r2 squared theta 2
dot and that's also in the K direction
but we know that r2 is r1 divided by 2
so we can plug that in I'll bring this
over here so M r1 squared theta 1 dot is
M R 1 over 4 theta 2 dot so Ike solve
for theta 2 so if I shorten the length
by a factor of 2 the angular velocity
goes up by a factor of 4
and let's check the kinetic energy
kinetic energy state one one-half M v1
squared one-half M v1 is our theta1dot
quantity squared but I have this is I
have some expressions for this r2 is our
1 over 2 theta 2 is 4 theta 1 dot
quantity squared and I could take you
multiply that out
yeah so where is the kinetic energy come
from
so she says we add energy the system by
pulling down so we're doing some work
right yeah there's tension in that
string equal to M R Omega squared if you
pull it down a certain distance in fact
R 1 over 2 you're going to do work
that's the integral of the tension times
dr you integrate it right and that work
goes in to there's conservation of
energy in the system that goes into
speeding up the rotation and yet the
angular momentum has stayed constant
throughout the action so I when I first
saw this years ago I thought that's
really cool that's really quite amazing
so nice application of conservation of
angular momentum an application of using
our this formula the time rate of change
of angular momentum with respect to a
point it tells you about the torques
applied to the system and this is in
fact a pretty simple case so the last
let's move on now to doing a little more
complicated case and this is the last
problem similar to the last problem in
the homework
so this is like the horror the homework
you got this monkey running up the shaft
right so I don't have a monkey and it's
not running up the shaft but I do have
just this particle on a shaft rotating
about a central axis now this is a
mechanical necessity to hold it all
together but if it's ignore the mass of
this centerpiece for the moment just
think of this as a massless arm with a
particle on it and I want to do I want
to calculate angular momentum we want to
calculate forces I want to calculate
torques and see what happens
so I'm going to start by putting my oh X
Z frame right on the level with this
mass what I'm going to show you now is
that where you put the reference point
about which you compute the angular
momentum matters you get different
answers depending on where you put it so
I'm going to start by putting it here
okay and this will call us out here's my
point a here's oh this is some angle fee
here and if this has some length L then
this up here is my R equals L cosine fee
and this is this side to be L sine fee
these are just the two lengths but I'm
going to use polar coordinates so this
is going to be my R hat direction theta
hats into the board
let's compute and it's a particle so
I'll continue to use lowercase H of a
with respect to O 2 vector is R of a
with respect to O cross P and linear
momentum with respect to O this is our R
hat which is called this L cosine theta
just calling it our it's in the R hat
direction
cross with P and P we've done this two
or three times now today it's the mass
times R times theta dot that's its speed
and it's in the theta hat direction
so taking the cross for our cross our
hat cross theta hat gives me a pain so I
get M R squared theta dot okay
very simple expression now this is a
fixed axis rotation so I want to compute
the torques look at my formula the VA
the the VA in this case is a placebo the
point of the axis of rotation doesn't
move so the second terms go away and I
can say that the torque of my particle
at a with respect to O is just D H a DT
so M is a constant R is a constant K is
a constant the only thing that has a
time derivative is theta dot and it
becomes theta double dot this is M R
squared theta double dot K and that is
equal well that's equal to the sum of
the external torques so what's what
physically does that mean that's what
physically is that telling us it's
telling us theta double dot is the
angular acceleration of this thing
speeding up going faster and faster
it takes torque to make that happen if
they if it's going at constant rate
what's theta double dot zero so at
constant rate the torque required to
make this thing go constant rate is zero
makes sense but if it were speeding up
if you're making it go faster and faster
and faster
it requires torque to drive it and
that's the amount of torque and the
torque is in the around the axis of spin
okay pretty straightforward
so if I did DPD if I took the time
derivative of just the linear momentum
for this particle we've done it here
today I took the time derivative it what
would I get it's a force and what's the
force say constant rotation rate take
the time derivative of P DP DT gives me
mass times the MV squared over R its
mass times acceleration the acceleration
of which kind centripetal so you just
get the same thing back again so there's
a there is a force acting in words on
this thing to make it go in a circle
that is the M R theta dot squared term
that we've seen so many times okay but
now what I want to do is move the point
about which I compute this angular
momentum
and now I'm going to put it here the
point of attachment of the arm
so here's o X Z everything else stays
the same all of them is move the point
and I want to compute the angular
momentum of this a with respect to O
well that's our this is now our B R of a
with respect to O this vector this
distance here in polar cylindrical
coordinates is Z and this is our just as
before they are hasn't changed and there
is an R hat in this direction theta hat
into the board and a K hat in the Z
direction those are our unit vector so
this is our AO is our R hat plus Z K hat
that's the position vector and I'm going
to cross that with the momentum of a
with respect to O
and the momentum is M R theta dot is the
velocity and what is it what's its
direction theta hat right mass times
velocity momentum and now we have a we
need to carry this out the R hat term
times theta hat gives you a K M R
squared theta dot K and the Z this term
K cross theta hat gives me a minus R
minus M R Z theta dot ok all right
okay yeah right your thank you because
if I would have a disaster if I let that
progress this looks like that right K
cross theta is minus R hat okay R cross
theta is a k k cross theta is a minus R
I get two terms and this is now an
expression for the angular momentum of a
with respect to O and see if I have
enough room to draw it here there is a
piece of it here that's this this is H
in the H in the Z direction is this
arrow and then there's a piece in the R
hat direction like this this is H in the
R hat direction
and the sum of those two is that so this
is H a with respect to O this guy
perpendicular to the shaft it will turn
out really is perpendicular if you work
out the numbers totally different result
than when I did it here so this one mr
squared theta k mr squared theta okay
hey that turned the same so when I did
this I got just the K term and now I've
moved this thing down and I get a second
term so now what we want to know is what
about the torques in the system so the
so I want to take the time derivative of
this sky with respect to the time
derivative of the angular momentum which
is going to be equal to the summation of
the external torques with respect to O
but o is now in a different place and so
I have to carry out these derivatives
and this one I did before this one just
gives me my M R squared theta double dot
k hat now this term M does is a constant
R is a constant zis a constant theta dot
is not necessarily constant I'm going to
let that be variable and our hat is
certainly changing direction so when I
take the derivative of this I'm going to
get two terms so the first one is minus
M R C theta double dot R hat and that's
taken the derivative of this x that the
second term is the derivative of this x
that and so the derivative of our hat is
theta dot theta at right okay so minus M
R Z theta dot theta dot theta hat so in
other words this is squared now I have
three terms to mess with we know what
the first term you know what the first
term means talked about that
what's this is the tour these are all
torques so this is the torque required
to do what the lead term
to make it go faster change its angular
speed right it's just building up the
angular momentum in that spin okay
so this is the angular spin up okay
these other two terms these are strange
things well first let's take a look at
this one
our theta dot squared what's that remind
you of what kind of torque is usually
some force times the moment arm cross
with a moment arm right so we know that
there's some forces acting in this
system it's spinning we know that there
is a in order to make this thing go
around and around there has to be it has
centripetal acceleration therefore there
must be a force being applied by this
shaft inward that's equal to the mass
times the centripetal acceleration M R
theta dot squared so here this guy is M
R theta dot squared that's the force and
so let's let's do these is call this a
let's call this term here be this term C
so the C term is torque C I'll call it
is some R cross some F and the F I'm
telling you is this in the centripetal
acceleration times the mass and that
will probably be then like an ant minus
M R squared
I'm R theta dot squared R hat
right and what about the moment arm that
that acts about what moment arm is
perpendicular force that's acting in
what moment arm is perpendicular to that
because only things perpendicular to it
lead to torques hmm Z K cross R should
give me a theta sure enough there's a -
sure enough there's a Z you multiply
this out you get this term so this this
is a strange term it's in the theta hat
direction what you know what is that so
if it's spinning and it's lined up like
this beta hats in that direction
positive K positive theta positive R hat
K's in that direction that's telling you
that there's a torque being applied
about this point in the minus theta hat
direction that makes sense you have a
it's pulley there's a sin trip
centripetal acceleration times a mass
there's a sports times a moment arm this
force is trying to bend this thing out
right if you if this thing had a hinge
down here and I started to spin it what
it would do it just flop out right
there's got to be a torque keeping that
from happening and that's a torque but
what's the goal that way it's got to be
a torque going the other way
keeping it in place and that's what that
term is
okay so now we know so this is the Euler
this is a spin up this is keeping this
thing from flopping out what's this guy
so this is yet another torque and it's
in the R -
direction so let's see if we can
intuitively figure this one out
well let's there's an R theta double dot
that should look familiar
R theta double dot if this thing is
accelerating in angular acceleration
speeding up out here that mass is in
order for I'm here right now in order
for me to go a little bit faster I'm
accelerating in that direction there
must be a force being applied by this
rod in that direction and that force
times a moment arm perpendicular to it Z
is a moment in the r direction so as
this thing spins up if this thing could
it would fall back but this rod is stiff
and won't let it do that so this is the
torque down here that is required keep
this thing moving
okay so this is really quite quite
amazing the do either of these torques
these second ones this one and this one
do they contribute to do they do any
work they add energy to the system see
work means force through a distance you
know they don't do actually any work
they are static torques just required to
hold the system together this one does
some work it actually makes it this one
leads to energy accumulating is going
faster and faster and faster these are
just holding the thing together but the
amazing thing is that you can use when
you can use an angular momentum to
calculate things like these torques so
if you were designing this this these
forces acting on this lump out here are
producing torques about this point which
are the same thing as in two double one
you'll be doing bending moments it
creates a bending moment
in this shaft and if you don't make the
shaft strong enough it will break it off
so the torque about this point is is the
bending moment in the r direction and in
the theta direction this is trying to be
bent in two different ways and you could
calculate the stresses down here caused
by those moments and that would help you
design the thing so you not only get
dynamics information out of taking
things like the time rate of change of
angular momentum you get some of the
static information as well the other
thing to remember the really important
point of the lecture is that angular
momentum what changes depending on where
you pick us a reference point so when we
pick the reference point just opposite
it we got none of the information about
the torques down here because with
respect to this point there are no
torques except the one to speed it up
the centripetal force here doesn't cause
torques the force out here that there
are no other torques just the one that
make it spin faster but as soon as I
move it down here
I learned something of considerable
value okay so the prom' work problem has
much as some of the same things on it
except the monkeys moving so you get
even a little bit more interesting
information out of it all right
okay so that went faster than I thought
so that gives them time for some
questions I got see several so we'll
start there and then go here so say
again your dis term you're asking about
this term okay you want me to explain
again what this one means this is a term
associated with increasing the angular
speed right so let's see if we can't
so this B term I'll call it the torque
associated with B minus M R Z theta
double dot R hat now that is going to be
some R cross some F and if we can get
some physical insight if we could figure
out what it what they are so the mass
the force is the mass times an
acceleration there's an acceleration R
theta double dot which is the speed of
this thing is increasing speed okay so
the and the R is going to be Z ZK hat
cross and I'm guessing that it's a force
that looks like M R theta double dot and
this is in the theta hat direction K
cross theta hat gives you minus R hat R
hat and the minus so this looks like a
plausible explanation for where this
might have come from so this is the
force speeding up attempting to speed up
this mass there's a force pushing on it
that's given to it by this rod this rod
is pushing on it to make it go faster
mass times acceleration would be M R
theta double dot and the moment arm is
this distance from here down to the
point at which I've been computing my
reference point from here to here that's
Z so force times Z R cross F puts it in
the ends up in the minus R direction
it's got to be this direction K cross
theta hat the force is this way
think about this forces that way they
are is this way the R cross F is this
way
and that's where you get the minus sign
it's in the minus R hat direction
but it comes from the drums trying to
speed up this mass and if you if this
was a floppy weak link as it tries to
speed up it would try to bend back it
would flop back as this thing tries to
make it go faster it will say no I don't
want to go lay back on me that would be
be going in the this way to keep from
doing that you have to put a torque on
it this way just trying to speed up is
trying to lay back and you're saying no
can't do that go like this okay so
that's the B term
how do you know where to set it well so
that's a good question he's saying how
do you when you doing a problem like
this how do you know where to pick the
reference frame well ask yourself what
it is you want to know and in fact if
now that you know that from angular
momentum of a mechanical thing you can
actually get static torques and the
system ask yourself where you want to
know those stores in this case if you're
designing this you want to know whether
you're going to break this thing off and
it's probably going to break right down
at the bottom where the moment arms are
the greatest so that's why you pick that
point so why you know comes a lot with
the experience will help you to choose
but the amazing thing is this
information is also all stored in the
angular momentum if you pick it in the
right place another hand okay I yes
Phillip yep
so I've been using polar cap so I just
been using polar coordinates and polar
coordinates is cylindrical technically
this problem has a Z Direction upwards
our Direction radially outwards R hat
and theta as drawn here it would be into
the board given the position of the mass
looking down on it here's my O and
looking down this would be my X and my Y
and this is some random arbitrary
position here and this is Theta looking
down on it in this plane is our hat
theta hat k hat coming out of the board
side view X Z and my system is like this
now the theta is into the board and the
R Direction is this way that's our hat
and this is Z this is the Z coordinate
upwards so the position vector the thing
we call our a with respect to O is
indeed the length of this whole thing
but it is made up of a component in the
Z Direction plus a component here that
we call our in the R hat direction okay
which are you referring to you talking I
mean which example this guy or okay so
two point tell me what you mean here
yeah when we computed it not here but
down here yeah a theta component of what
angular or momentum
she's asking shouldn't there be a theta
component of angular momentum
so we computer angular momentum with
this formula at the top it's an R cross
P so the R consists of a Z part and the
are part it's exactly this right here
and the P is only into the board it's
only in the theta hat direction so you
have a term that's our hat cross theta
hat gives you a K and you have a term K
cross K cross theta hat which gives you
an R there just are no products that
come out of this that are in the theta
hat direction yeah
that's the in this case that's why polar
coordinates are nice because as it spins
the theta hat is constantly going with
it the our hats constantly going with it
right and so then beauty of this thing
is it's this is actually is it actually
kind of a symmetric problem it goes
round and round and the the torques are
with our are given out in this rotating
frame if you wanted I think maybe it's
confusing you is if you wanted to know
the torques in a fixed inertial frame
you'd have to break them down into X IJ
K components in which you could do
little tedious but with the answers and
this one came out and artha hat theta
hat K hat terms okay
happy dancer this is good stuff but
thick so keep other questions
so what do you think will happen in that
final homework problem with the monkey
running but now he has some velocity how
will that problem differ from what we've
done you have a question you can want to
answer that yeah it's going to what it's
going to look like a circle okay you'll
be going in a circle at any spiral he'll
be going yeah like a helix huh all right
yeah the monkey will be going into helix
yeah what forces will act on that monkey
and what direction do you think there
will be forces acting on it he's hanging
up he's hanging on for dear life you
know this thing going around he could
throw him off right so what forces act
and therefore if you can figure out what
forces act so you draw Freebody diagram
in the monkey there's going to be
possibly forces in that they'd have
direction in the Z direction in the r
direction okay but to think physically
where they come from so we now know that
certainly he's hanging on because there
is he is undergoing centripetal
acceleration and in order to force him
to go in that circle there has to be an
inward force applied by this shaft to
him so there's a force like that because
of this entropy ttle acceleration there
if it's speeding up there's a force
pushing him to make it go faster but
he's running up a shaft what else is
there is there are there any other
accelerations
yeah his angular acceleration that's the
thing trying to speed up and so he's
hanging on because this thing has got
accelerating like he's pushing her back
in the car seat right linear
acceleration well this is trying to at
any instant time it's trying to go
faster so he's having to hang on because
of that so that's one of those terms
okay but now he's moving he's also
running up the shaft will that lead to
any other accelerations and force equals
mass times acceleration so every time
you can if you're going to account for
all the accelerations in the system
multiply it by M you've accounted for
all of the forces some of the forces of
the mass times acceleration if you add a
new acceleration you better add a new
force if you add a new force you
probably added a new torque well gravity
yep what else oh so he's suggesting
there might be a Coriolis acceleration
and the Coriolis acceleration in order
to make the monkey accelerate according
to that term there will have to be yet
another force and I think so you should
do also see if that turns up in the in
the calculation okay you've got a couple
minutes I want you to take through the
muddy cards you know think about and
then at the on your way out
just I think just pile them up down here
on the table or hand them to hand them
to me or one of the TAS and that'll help
me understand what you understood or
didn't understand today